hello there I'm Joe Alvin I'm the
editor-in-chief at Glamour magazine and
I'm here with the wonderful - Lisa hop
star extraordinaire we haven't seen her
for quite some time so I'm desperate to
know everything about first of all
before you give me a high five wherever
you be what have you been up to
um I've been in the studio I've been
writing music what I have heard is
really lovely and summery it's a
beautiful sign of why that song was
spontaneous we were in the studio and we
were making a beat and then one of the
guys in the studio were like why don't
we do like a big old school garage
anthem a commercial one and do a modern
day mix of it a cover and so we
literally going over all the classics
singing it over the B and then
eventually it just came to me and I went
sweet like chocolate started singing the
chorus and I went oh my gosh
oh my god listen to this and it just fit
the track perfectly perfectly and
everyone just literally in the room went
oh my god
on balance how do you feel about having
done be expected I can never ever you
know I get the whole thing of it being
that double-edged sword
anyone that becomes a judge in the show
gets mass press and media and it's
life-changing but I can never look back
on my time they're all that decision to
go to that level and regret it because
it's it's made me who I am it's been a
part of the journey I like to just ride
the wave and that's what I've done I'm
happy with the person I am now and all
of that is what it has got me here so
what do you think was your best and
worst experience at that show oh the
best obviously without a doubt I don't
even know why I thought about winning
with Little Mix well you know that and
like what an island I mean your
publicist said to me everybody forgets
that she really created Little Mix yeah
I never did forget that going through
those motions together knowing I was a
part of something so amazing how much
their lives have changed and I got to be
a part of that was there a lower moment
on the user
something you're really glad you don't
have to go through again I never liked
anyone wooden or found it easy to turn
around to people and say that was a bad
performance and because you're on a TV
show you can't just sit there and be
laid-back and casual about and say yeah
was a too keen on that one but anyway
moving on you have to go into it you
need to give a a wide range when it
comes to your critique yeah so it
demands me to elaborate on anything that
I'm feeling or thinking I remember your
dressing room because I your dressing
room used to be Dannii Minogue dressing
room yeah and I you still up because
like her dressing room was pretty much
I don't remember literally well music
but it's kind of fits the way he handles
a baby maybe a glass of wine probably
not yeah going to Talisa stress which is
the saiga
why Dana to read a hiatus it could not
be more different but you yeah was the
party yeah yeah I'd agree that I was the
I was the youngest judge people forget I
came onto that show at the age of 22 I
wanted to have fun and you know after
every shot one everyone to come into my
room
hey let's bounce music let's have a
laugh as have a dream are you still that
party girl honestly you could go as far
to say I have a slight boring edge
I believe honestly you know don't get me
wrong when if I'm having fun I'm going
to have fun but I need a lot of quiet
time I've started meditation I even
trade in kung-fu I'm into my juice in my
healthy eating my whole lifestyle has
taken a massive turn what's brought that
change for you I think in the past year
is when there's been a real it kind of
it was there and it was simmering and
then in the past year I just thought to
myself hey I've always wanted to do
martial arts I'm gonna do martial arts
I've read I wouldn't you know I want to
read into meditation understand how to
do it let me do it and then as I started
to
to do these things and change my diet
and my physical well-being
my mental stay the more I started to
enjoy it and feel better in this I know
it's cliche the feeling love in a piece
and very calm and at one with yourself
and just generally happier it just
sounds like you've let go of a lot of
anger yeah yeah is that right yeah I
have let go of a lot of anger I think
society these days not just the press
it's just people we've become really
judgmental and really detach from
people's emotions we just seem to become
so used to just judging and and we think
it's having an opinion or well this is
my right to speak but sometimes it's
just being plain and we all need to
separate maybe take a sit back and
reconnect with each other I've been
guilty of it in the past how do you feel
then when I mean I can't think of
anything specific but we all get it we
all get crap on so yeah idea how do you
handle that how did how does it make you
feel it in the earlier days I used to
buy into it I used to buy it I was I was
pretty bad and those were my defense
mechanism days whereas now it's just
literally does not I don't know why or
how I think it's life experience I've
changed the person I'm I am but I
couldn't tell you this psychology behind
it it just doesn't get to anymore
what's your attitude knows you cosmetic
in heart ah okay what do you know what
um I know as a reason I'm aware there's
been a lot of things in the press and
everyone keeps saying she's had more
work done she's having more done and
literally for the past year and a half I
haven't done anything other than
collagen waves and non-invasive beauty
treatments like not even cosmetic
enhancement so is it oh I'm done with
that I'll never say I still get my lips
done I still love beauty and I still
love treatments the end of the day it's
a business for me this I do separate
work and like I said my my home bubble
my reality so I know that my looks my
figure is a part of my business how do
you how do you feel um you know you've
mentioned what are you 28 29 28 no just
turns any old just turn
so yeah but how do you feel about
approaching 30 my god you've done so
much I'm trying to think about it really
I know it's silly because there's people
obviously older than myself going I'll
stop it you're a baby but everyone does
that it's like when I'm my age and then
I look at a 20 year old I go you're a
baby
but that's ready rolled when you turn in
past your twenties leaving you teens
it's always that stage isn't it of like
okay I'm no longer a teenager okay
I'm no longer in my 20s okay I'm hitting
the day face looking so great and
obviously feeling so well
yeah and happy and just you know come
and coordinate on my sofa beautifully
jacket any time alive had not shaven
thank you good to have a [ __ ] as usual
yes
hey guys to hear more from me Talisa
subscribe to glamour UK below